>> I THINK THE BIG PROBLEM THIS
CORRECT.
COUNTRY HAS IS BEING POLITICALLY
AND I DON’T FRANKLY HAVE TIME
FOR TOTAL POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, THIS
COUNTRY DOESN’T HAVE TIME EITHER
COUNTRY DOESN’T HAVE TIME EITHE
EITHER.
>> Jedidiah: A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ARE NOW AGREEING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS HAS GONE TOO FAR.
52% NOW SAYING THEY ARE AGAINST
THE COUNTRY BECOMING MORE PC AND
ARE UPSET THAT THERE ARE TOO
MANY THINGS THAT PEOPLE CAN’T
SAY ANYMORE.
SHOULD 2020 DEMOCRATS PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS WARNING SIGN?
GREG, I SAY ALL THE TIME I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS HE
GOT ELECTED.
PEOPLE ARE SO TIRED OF NOT BEEN
ABLE TO SPEAK THEIR MINDS,
HAVING TO BITE THEIR TONGUES.
IT’S THE MOST DANGEROUS TIME IN
THE WORLD TO BE A COMEDIAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: I AM ALARMED.
52% IS NOT A LOT.
IT’S NOT ENOUGH.
I THOUGHT IT SAID 37 OR 38 IN
FAVOR.
THERE WAS SOME OTHER MIDDLE
GROUND THERE.
HERE’S THE DANGER WITH THE
CORRECTNESS.
CONCEPT OF POLITICAL CORRECTNES
IT MORPHS.
THE WHOLE POINT OF IT IS THAT
IT’S COSTLY CHANGING AND
PROGRESSING OVER TIME.
IT EXPANDS LIKE A BLOB.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS EXCEPT ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE NOW, SO
THEY DREDGE UP THINGS YOU SAID
TWO YEARS AGO THROW IT IN YOUR
FACE.
POSITIONED AS A SAFETY BLANKET
BUT IT’S BEEN SPREAD OVER THE
CULTURE AND IT IS SUFFOCATING
REAL SPEECH.
THE ONLY SOLUTION TO THIS, AND
ALSO THE ONE SCARY THING ABOUT
PC, IF YOU FORGIVE SOMEBODY FOR
DOING SOMETHING THAT’S
CONSIDERED A VIOLATION OF A PC
THING, YOU ARE AN ACCESSORY TO
THE RACISM OR SEXISM OR
HOMOPHOBIA OR TRANS PHOBIA
THAT’S OCCURRED.
YOU CAN EVEN -- PC THINKING
ELIMINATES THE CONCEPT OF
FORGIVENESS, WHICH IS HOW OUR
CIVILIZATION IS BUILT.
PEOPLE MAKING MISTAKES.
THE SOLUTION HERE, AND I’VE SAID
IT BEFORE, PEOPLE HAVE TO SHARE
THE RISK.
COMEDIANS, WRITERS, ARTISTS,
TALK SHOWS.
WHEN THEY SEE SOMEBODY LIKE MIKA
OR WHOEVER DO SOMETHING STUPID,
YOU DON’T TAKE OUT THE
PITCHFORKS AND THE TORCHES.
YOU FORGIVE THEIR APOLOGY, AND
YOU MOVE ON.
THAT’S THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU’RE
GOING TO REDUCE THE HYSTERICAL
HISTRIONICS, YES, THAT WE ARE
PARALYZED BY.
COMPANIES IN FEAR.
COMPANIES IN FEAR BECAUSE
SOMEBODY’S GOING TO COME AFTER
YOU.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
>> Jedidiah: THE CHALLENGE IS
IT’S NOT JUST FEAR WHAT YOU
MIGHT SAY NOW.
IT’S FEAR OF WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
EVER SAID EVER THAT NOW YOU HAVE
ON TWITTER AND ALL THAT STUFF.
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT -- I WAS
IMPRESSED WITH THE NUMBERS JUST
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK, IT’S
REPUBLICAN MEN, WOMEN,
DEMOCRATIC MEN AND WOMEN, ALL
FOR COMING OUT SAYING THEY FEEL
THEY CAN’T SPEAK THEIR MINDS
WHEN THEY USE TO WHICH MEANS
IT’S REGISTERING.
I HAVE TO WALK ON EGGSHELLS.
>> Dana: I WONDER WHAT THE AGE
BREAKDOWN IS.
I IMAGINE IF PEOPLE LIKE MAYBE
US AND OLDER.
>> Jedidiah: IT’S OVER 30.
>> Greg: THERE IS A LOT OF
YOUNG KIDS WHO DON’T BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IT’S SCARY.
>> Dana: THEY DON’T LIKE IT.
>> Pete: DEMOCRATS, ADULTS
UNDER 30, AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
FAVOR OF MORE PC.
>> Dana: YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
REELECTION, SHOULD DEMOCRATS
THINK ABOUT IT?
YEAH, MAYBE THIS TERM.
BUT IN 2024, MILLENNIALS ARE THE
LARGEST VOTING GROUP.
THEY ARE SURPASSING BABY
BOOMERS.
GENERATION X IS PRETTY SMALL.
YOU CAN’T TELL A JOKE TO A
MILLENNIAL.
IT’S PRETTY FUNNY THAT THEY
THINK THAT "THE OFFICE" IS
HILARIOUS.
THAT’S NOT PC.
>> Jedidiah: ISN’T THERE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY AND CULTURAL
HYPERSENSITIVITY?
YOU CAN BE SENSITIVE WITHOUT
BEING GOING SO FAR.
>> Pete: WATCHING EPISODES
"THE OFFICE."
THEY WOULD NEVER AIR THAT TODAY.
TRUMP HAS SERVED AS A SHIELD FOR
PEOPLE WHO FELT STIFLED.
HE CAN STAND UP AND SAY
POCAHONTAS.
HE CAN SAY IT.
I CAN SAY IT.
CULTURE INTRODUCES IT.
WE SHOULD BE OKAY WITH IT.
SPEECHES ON THE SURFACE OF THE
PROBLEM.
IT’S INSTITUTIONS
INSTITUTIONALIZING IT.
K-12 PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES
IN MEDIA AND CHURCHES IN MOVIES
AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE CHRISTMAS AND THE FLAG, AND
YOU WONDER HOW DID I GET HERE?
55% OF THOSE IDENTIFIED AS
DEMOCRATS FAVOR MORE POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
YOUR PARTY IS SAYING WE WANT
MORE OF THIS.
>> Juan: THINK ABOUT IT.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE STRONGEST
PROPONENT OF BEING TOO
POLITICALLY CORRECT OUR OLDER
WHITE MEN.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT’S TWO-THIRDS OF THEM SAY THIS
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IS
TERRIBLE.
IT STINKS.
WITH ANY ASK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
BEEN DENIGRATED IN THE PAST,
LIKE BLACKS, THEY SAY OH, NO.
WE DON’T LIKE IT.
NOT ONLY THAT, IT’S SO
INTERESTING TO ME.
70% IN THIS POLL SAID THINGS ARE
WORSE IN TERMS OF CIVILITY UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT TRUMP HAS NOW EMBOLDEN
PEOPLE TO SAY WHATEVER THEY WANT
ABOUT WHOEVER THEY WANT.
>> Jedidiah:
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE OFFENSIVE AND
POLITICALLY INCORRECT TOO.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE WAY
FORWARD.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO BE OFFENSIVE.
TO BE INSULTED AND TO INSULT.
IF YOU TAKE THE OPPOSITE TACK
AND SAY MY FEELINGS NEED TO BE
PROTECTED, THAT’S AN
IMPOSSIBILITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN BE PROTECTED.
YOU WILL HAVE THESE ISSUES AND
THE DIVISIVENESS.
IF EVERYBODY SAID YOU CAN OFFEND
ME AS MUCH AS YOU WANT AND I CAN
OFFEND YOU, WE ARE EQUALS.
WE ARE BROTHERS.
>> Dana: WE SHOULD TAKE DAN
CRENSHAW’S EXAMPLE.
DAN CRENSHAW GOES ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE."
I GUESS THEY ARE FRIENDS, HIM
AND PETE DAVIDSON.
EVERYONE SAID THAT’S THE MODEL
WE SHOULD FOLLOW.
SO LET’S DO THAT.
>> Jedidiah: EVERYONE SAYS
THAT DOES THE OPPOSITE.
YOU DEFEND YOUR TEAM BUT WHEN IT
SOMEONE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Juan: I THINK IT’S PROGRESS
AND WE NEED TO STOP BULLYING AND
NAME-CALLING, DEMONIZING OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THE LEFT NEVER DOES
THAT.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK IT’S
GOOD THAT BACK IN THE ’50s YOU
COULD SAY THIS ABOUT A WOMAN.
>> Greg: I AM TALKING ABOUT
LANGUAGE.
I AM TALKING ABOUT SILENCING
LANGUAGE ON CAMPUS.
I’M TALKING ABOUT HOW IT’S
SPREADING INTO A DANGEROUS
PLACE.
YOU WROTE A BOOK ON THIS.
>> Juan: YEAH, I DON’T LIKE
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
I’M A BIG FREE SPEECH ADVOCATE.
BUT YOU AND I TALKING ABOUT GAY